- HEY.
MAN, WHERE ARE THEY?
- JUST TALKED TO 'EM.
GUESS WHAT. THEY'RE NOT COMIN'.
- WHAT?
- YEAH.
RIGHT NOW,
THEY'RE IN THE CAR,
DRIVING TO VERMONT
TO START A NEW LIFE TOGETHER.
THEY'RE GONNA OPEN UP SOME KIND
OF GLUTEN-FREE CUPCAKE PLACE
CALLED, "CUP GAYKES."
GENIUS NAME, I KNOW.
- WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO?
[club dance music]
- EVEN A STRAIGHT MAN,
WHO'S HAD SEX
WITH OVER FIVE WOMEN,
CAN CHANNEL...
THE GAYLORD'S FORCE!
- WHOO!
[cheers and applause]
- OW.
OH, [bleep]!
OH, THAT'S HOT.
THAT WAS HOT.
I AM ADAM
"BABY BEAR" DEMAMP!
I SHALL SUMMON THE POWER
OF ALL THE GAYLORDS!
[cheers and applause]
[grunts]
WHOO!
DO SOMETHIN' DIFFERENT.
OH, YOU WANNA SEE ME
BREAK A BOARD OVER MY OWN SKULL?
[thumps]
[bleep].
- AH...
[chuckles]
HOW'D WE DO?
- PRETTY GOOD.
TOTAL TICKET SALES, 285 BUCKS.
- OH, GET 'EM!
- HA!
BUT, UH, LEMME
CALCULATE SOMETHING ELSE.
WE SPENT 50 BUCKS ON GLITTER...
- OKAY, OKAY.
- 150 FOR CHAIRS, AND THEN,
LIKE, THE STAGE STUFF.
- AH, THAT SUCKS.
- AND THEN
THIS IS THE KILLER.
$300 ON THE BOAS,
BECAUSE THEY JUST HAD TO BE
REAL OSTRICH FEATHERS.
both: RAM.
- WHAT A DIVA.
- UM, SO,
ALL THAT TOGETHER,
WE ARE IN THE HOLE
FOR A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY.
- ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S TERRIBLE.
- 703 PAGES...
OF BUSINESSES
AND PERSONAL RESIDENTS!
[audience chanting Baby Bear]
NOW, ARE YOU READY?
OH, IT'S NOT PRE-RIPPED!
NOT AT ALL! ARE YOU READY?
GAY...
LORD'S...
FORCE!